Oh
[music]
hmm me pip pip
yeah
[music]
Huh wow this store
is like a narcissist Shinotsu morning Shan morning shower And then
dustproof in front of the mirror, but it's
good, Onii-chan  It's the same old commandment
y Eat that kind of junk food in the morning
En
Aso
Now, I told you not to come into my room without permission, right
?  I
've decided I
won't go back to those days when I was spoiled and helpless
Hayo,
you have to have breakfast here Nakar I used
to love donuts from science as a kid, didn't I?
You've cut a lot of things off, do you want to go?
Why are you
b 2 f
Show me that cell phone It's this time I
was just trying to text
you, right
?  I carelessly used my cell phone, but I'm going to take more time than him.
It's really, really, really, really, really, really, really
great
.
It looks like it's possible I might be able to go to my white house
[music]
Senpai in the basement is going to fall into the cruel princess confession version this time No
matter how cruel the princess is, senior Shigeo is super handsome
I'm used to people's gazes, so I want an answer here,
isn't it?
new due to winter demand  The number of people in Sanjing has increased I
'm sorry I've been to
the bookstore in Station 6
recently.
I don't think it's a bad preparation to stare unnaturally at Se's upper arm.
From the mole for women to the next cable
I'll call you here and offer you seven hot springs Papa
me
[music]
I used to like it quite a bit, but I
'm
sorry if I listen to Shige's book
I'm scared of something like this, what should
I
do?
[music]
me
[applause]
[music]
me
[applause]
[music]
I don't like
it Miyata no more  I'm sorry
, I slept well in Hayama where I was.
Ah
, it's proof that I've become accustomed to school when I suddenly became the chairman of the bookkeeping committee
.
It's okay to stipulate you,
Shriek,
and the bell tower.
The feeling of a wall is amazing. Praying for grades, you're not arrogant, you can play sports,
and you're cool.
There's someone with the same high specs, but
Ah, about
that person -1,
I'm in the store room today
.
No, no, it's
me
[music]
I fell in love with your dignified straightness when I went to the
second second You like my spats legs  From
today onwards, I'm going to call you a real thug Hah,
Yoshino Ikai
Ah,
what is it, he's at the top of his grade and is a very beautiful woman, but
unlike Makabe-kun, he has a late personality and
hates men so much that he confesses to me, senior?  That's why I'm going to repel it with a saga
.
That's why it's called a
cruel princess. It's Takaaki-san.
Music] Mr.
Aki, my alma mater,
thank you for the second serving.
There's a lot of it
Oh my God, the ribbon is about to come untied
[Music]
I thought girls were afraid of me, but it seems like some girls say it's cool when they're clear about it or not Is
that the way it
is?  Susumu Koiwai is
here, and
I haven't heard much about his preferences, thoughts, or tendencies, but I've heard that he likes to eat lunch alone
.
Nagokigen is dangerous Aki-sama tee Hmmm.
A woman who usually surrounds herself with entourage and enjoys a harem situation
is not like that at dinner time
.
There shouldn't be such a thing only for me I say it's
gorgeous and
I'm the mayor, right?
Yes,
there's no
doubt Akio Akio
's sidekick.
I only had 3 cutlet sandwiches, so why not just buy something random?
I didn't mean to peek at the
rice.
I didn't think I'd
let you in Come on, what
is
it?  I wonder if I can get it, it does
n't have to be you, ska oc There must be some girls in the sports club who eat a large bento
, and my sister also
puts bread away today.
I'm about to go back to a duel, and I have to resupply 2 cups of rice
.
I have a
child, but I want you to become a 4 with Spitz, that
's right x I remembered it, so it's fine,
tan
Your name is
Kame.  Where's the information that they're on good terms?
Plus x, rumors are circulating.
How
can you fantasize to that extent? A
girl's romance is like this
That beautiful girl is in the 10-day Bunpei Building
I can't believe it, am I a dog
?  Weapons
hahahaha
[music]
am
no take off your hips
love isn't a patent exclusive to girls huh?
Good
morning Yoshino Yoshino Wake up
I'm about to collapse on my stomach Please buy me something to eat
[Applause]
Hmmm
I should have eaten lunch right 7 It seems like my body is getting worse and worse on fuel
4 If I put it away, how far did you go to buy it?
It's fine if it's a new match, it's
fine if it's a letter from afar
I don't care about my face, let go of me
I'm a princess with curly hair
, huh?
Okay, you're the one who's cheaper Compared to your safety
[music]
Day
g
tsu I drew a mixed catch Probably overseas No, it
hurts  So
he can't do anything to me, haze That hole is empty I don't think Glide will allow me to know my secret and be protected from a pinch
[music]
Don't make that face girl  I'm cuter when I smile
[music] I
've got
[music]
Let's confess that I was fat On top of that, I'm a 30-year-old kid who gets bullied with a bonbon character
So I paid for
it What were you doing in front of my house?
I didn't like you until that moment when
you seemed like a savior to me.
I'm putting all my heart into
it I'm going to try to make you fall in love with me now
And when he gets serious I
'll let you know my true identity and throw it away in the best possible way
Oh,
haha,
why are you moving?
Stake
point get
[music]
I threw it
away
Oh, Tanabe Ku-spot
Good morning
Yesterday the rice was totally
fine Don't worry about it Ichimitsu
Aaaah
[music]
Good morning Makabe-kun
Labre  I don't know, I don't know about
this tournament.
]